three days of arguments for president
Trump's acquittal can be summarized as
this Trump didn't do what Democrats
accuse his lawyers say but even if he
did he should not be removed from office
the bar for impeachment cannot be set
this low Danger Danger Danger
Trump's lawyers downplayed recent
revelations from John Bolton the former
national security adviser who reportedly
writes in his upcoming book that Trump
withheld security aid to Ukraine in
order to get investigations into
Democrats including Joe Biden responding
to an unpublished manuscript that maybe
some reporters have an idea of maybe
what it says and that's what I mean
that's what the evidence if you want to
call that evidence I don't know what you
call that I called it an admissible but
Democrats want to call Bolton to testify
he hasn't done so yet under the
president's orders but says he will
appear if subpoenaed their whole
argument is diversion if you don't
believe the newspaper report call the
witnesses Democrats must convince at
least four Republicans to go along with
that idea
senator MIT Romney a moderate Republican
says he'll be one I'd like to hear from
John Bolton and I think the idea that's
been expressed in the media about having
each side be able to choose a witness or
maybe more than what West's witness on a
paired basis it has some merit
Republicans want to call Joe Biden and
his son hunter to testify Trump accuses
them of being involved in Ukrainian
corruption the basis for wanting their
investigation in New Jersey enthusiasm
for Trump's innocence was on display as
supporters camped out for days to attend
his campaign rally
polls show about half of Americans
believe Trump should remain in office
and half want him gone Heidi Joe Castro
al Jazeera Washington